ich muss darüber singen so einen
informations musik gegenüber cannabis
und auch ein bisschen politisch den
kampf aufnehmen
die flagge schwingen pro cannabis weil
halt so eine große ungerechtigkeit
herrschen diesem land und ich kann mir
schon gut vorstellen dass dann auch das
rappen über drogen dazu führen kann dass
mehr jugendliche um die es ja gerade
gehen muss dann auch anfangen drogen zu
nehmen und das ist etwas was mir sorge
bereitet und ich glaube schon dass man
dann als jemand der im rampenlicht steht
eine verantwortung übernehmen muss
macht kiffen kreativ oder abhängig
besonders im web wird sie zelebriert die
liebe zum ried ist das noch kunst oder
schon verherrlichung und was macht das
mit den fans sind sie gefährdet die
einen sagen auf keinen fall jedenfalls
nicht mehr als durch alkohol und die
anderen sagen na ja so einfach ist es
auch wieder nicht drogen sind zu recht
verboten
bevor jetzt gleich rapper und andere zu
wort kommen bei 310 fragen seid ihr
gefragt was meint ihr
cannabis legalisieren ja oder nein
schreibt sind die kommentare wir freuen
uns auf die diskussion und wer weiß
vielleicht ändert sich ja eure meinung
in dieser folge 13 fragen so die erste
runde ihr alle habt positionen und die
wollen wir jetzt deutlich machen damit
wir auch wissen wo ihr steht wenn ihr
die folgenden fragen mit ja beantwortet
dann würde ich euch bitten geht einen
schritt in richtung gelbes fällt wenn
ihr die folgenden fragen mit nein
beantwortet dann bitte ein schritt in
richtung grün gehen so bei den meisten
politiker innen hat cannabis ein sehr
schlechtes image frage ist zu recht ja
würde heißen richtung geld gehen nein
würde bedeuten richtung grün gehen
[Musik]
kiffen ist definitiv meine leidenschaft
cannabis wird aus meiner sicht zu
unrecht verdammt war für mich die
einstiegsdrogen ganz klar
zigaretten und tabak sind nicht kann als
suchttherapeut würde ich sagen das hat
zu recht ein schlechtes image schon sehr
viele leute behandelt die in ihrem leben
sehr viel sehr viel daneben gegangen ist
weil sie konsumieren die frage nummer
zwei cannabis muss illegal bleiben ja
heißt richtung gelb nein heißt richtung
grün bleibt stehen
ich bin davon überzeugt dass die
legalisierung von cannabis ein falsches
signal an jugendlichen senden würde denn
sie würde cannabis zu etwas alltäglichem
machen was einfach zu bekommen ist ich
halte dies für gefährlich ich bin für
die legalisierung die verbotspolitik ist
ein historischer irrtum und wir müssen
unbedingt über eine
gesundheitspolitische orientierte und
menschenrechts orientierte gestaltung
der drogenpolitik sprechen
kiffen wird verherrlicht in der
popkultur vor allem im rap stimmt ihr zu
richtung gelb sagt ironie das stimmt gar
nicht bitte richtung grün
[Musik]
cannabis wird im web und damit auch in
der popkultur verherrlicht es ist auf
jeden fall keine lösung so zu tun als
wären drogen nicht gefährlich cannabis
verherrlichung in der musikszene halte
ich für sehr komplex das thema aber die
kunstfreiheit muss bewahrt werden und
deswegen halte ich das für in ordnung
auch wenn es natürlich da auch so einen
faden beigeschmack haben könnte wenn man
jugendliche beeinflusst durch
jetzt wissen wir alle ungefähr wo ihr
steht wenig überraschend haben sich also
zwei fronten gebildet die frage ist wo
sich ihr kompromisse schaffe ich es euch
mit meinen fragen nachher auf dieses
kompromiss feld zu führen dass wir uns
also alle in der mitte wieder treffen
oder geht ihr sogar noch weiter
auseinander kann ja auch passieren
zweite runde
wenn ihr sagt ja dann geht ihr bitte
einen schritt vor wenn ihr sagt nein das
stimmt mich nicht zu dann geht der bitte
einen schritt zurück frage an die grüne
gruppe die zahl der cannabis konsumenten
in deutschland steigt seit jahren
gleichzeitig erhöht sich auch stetig der
thc-gehalt das heißt die drogen werden
stärker und wir haben mehr
konsumentinnen sendet die legalisierung
von cannabis nicht in dieser situation
genau das falsche signal an jugendliche
wenn ihr sagt ja kommt die bitte vor
wenn ihr sagt nein geht ihr bitte zurück
alle drei sagen nein
berlin warum sagst du nein die bei der
legalisierung debatte geht hier nicht
darum zu sagen ich sollte mehr kaufen
sondern es geht darum jugendlicher nicht
zu kriminalisieren und sie durch diese
entkriminalisierung auch zu
entstigmatisieren bei kriminalisierung
heißt verhaltenes geächtet und ich finde
es nicht in ordnung jugendliche für eine
entscheidung die sie treffen die
vielleicht nicht die beste fairere gegen
eine entwicklung es zu kriminalisieren
ich finde das argument teilweise richtig
und ich kann es auch verstehen border
ist ein stigma dahinter
ich würde sagen man braucht auf jeden
fall aufklärung der jugendlichen
aber ich finde es trotzdem richtig dass
wir die illegalität grundsätzlich haben
weil ich auch denke dass es ein
abschreckungseffekt haben könnte weil
man vielleicht vorher drüber nachdenkt
war das wäre jetzt was illegal ist was
ich mache mache ich das wirklich das
diesen jugendlichen geholfen werden muss
gerade wenn sie probleme haben
ich würde an der stelle gern ein haken
weil am ende treten wir bei einer
legalisierung von einer legalisierung
für erwachsene nicht für kinder oder
jugendliche die es dann erst recht nicht
kriegen sollten wir reden dann von einem
potentiell regulierten schwarzmarkt von
kontrollierten abgabestellen staatliche
oder behördliche überwachung
entkriminalisierung unfassbar viel
präventions- und aufklärungsarbeit die
möglich wird durch die ganzen
steuergelder also ich sehe da sehr viel
positives tatsächlich drin neben das
gleich mal auf das nächste frage an euch
gruppe gelb portugal drogen wurden
entkriminalisiert das heißt auch
cannabis konsumenten werden nicht mehr
inhaftiert sondern im zweifel eher
therapiert gleichzeitig ist die drogen
kriminalitätsrate gesunken und portugal
hat im schnitt weniger junge erwachsene
cannabiskonsumenten als die europäische
union insgesamt
offenbar kann ja die lockerung von
verboten zumindest bei cannabis durchaus
gutes bewirkt stimmt ihr zu dann kommt
dir vor du bist du halt vor
ich glaube weiterhin dass eine
illegalität auch immer noch einen
aufpassen verursacht und ich glaube auch
dass eine legalisierung dazu führen kann
dass wir es normalisieren in der
gesellschaft und das dann gerade
jugendliche möglicherweise er noch mal
cannabis konsumieren weil sie ja wissen
dass es normal ist zumindest für
erwachsene so dass ich eine
legalisierung weiterhin kritisch sehr
aber ich finde es unglaublich
interessant was da in portugal passiert
ist und würde mir wünschen dass wir das
weiter beobachten
auch während dessen die duh er dürfte
sofort gleich antwort haben vielleicht
ich würde gleich mal in die nächste
runde gehen weil so ein bisschen mehr
erfahrungen vielleicht hier
zusammenkommen dass auch jeder mal aus
seinem bereich ein bisschen erzählen
kann wie er es oder sie es erlebt hat
und warum er dann die oder jene position
hat das gilt natürlich auch für alle
menschen in unserer community welche
erfahrungen habt ihr damit uns
interessiert das natürlich schreibt sind
die kommentare habt ihr überhaupt drogen
kontakt gibt es in ihrem umfeld drogen
welche rolle spielen die und wie geht
ihr oder eure freunde und freundinnen
damit umfrage an dem wir gerade schon
gehört haben beschäftigt sie auch
journalistisch mit dem thema du hast
gesagt dass die rap-szene aktuell sehr
stark von drogen geprägt ist und sogar
sich zu einem pulverfass entwickelt hat
so hast du s genannt also auf den punkt
gebracht
wie drogen verherrlichend ist ein
deutscher rap ist auf jeden fall so dass
halt momentan rap und damit halt auch
popkultur web ist das größte musikshow
der welt halt richtig stark von den
us-amerikanischen genre beeinflusst ist
was in den 2001 entstanden ist was raps
oder rief heute wird man schritt nicht
mehr sagen weil es halt überall
eingeflossen ist und rap ist halt von
grund auf ein fach mit drogenkonsum
verbunden weil es darum geht musik zu
machen die sich auf drogen besonders
schön anhört und auch der ganze
lifestyle halt aus atlanta wurde per
kommt ist halt so das sind als soziale
brennpunkte wie wir uns in deutschland
nennen würden und das sind halt menschen
die durch rasseln also drogen verkaufen
irgendwie perspektive haben sich da nach
oben zu erarbeiten und dieses elend
hinter sich zu lassen und das spiel hat
alles so mit in die musik ein und da
macht deshalb sinn dass drogen halt so
eine große rolle in der musik spielen
weil das heißt die lebensrealität
widerspiegelt aber bei vielen es gibt
natürlich in deutschland auch so
na ja wir haben jetzt zwei kandidaten
hier herzog und marin sind ja in dieser
szene aktiv und machen auch texte wo es
auch um drogen geht ja willst du ihnen
das vor ja das kommt auf die songs an
also ich finde es gibt ja auch in
deutschland eine sehr sehr guten weg
halt drogen thematisch zu bearbeiten wie
immer in deutschland auch
lebensrealitäten wo menschen halt in
eine welt geboren werden die halt extrem
unfair essen wo die wir nicht chancen
haben und wo erstens der konsum von
drogen hat das elend erträgt er tragbar
macht und auch der verkauf von drogen
halt so eine der sehr wenigen
möglichkeiten ist da raus zu kommen und
ich bin da wenn man das thematisiert und
sogar verherrlicht oder einfach halt
zeigt dann dann zeigt es halt dass es so
selten gibt in denen drogen halt so der
einzige weg sind dann muss man gucken
die welten zu ändern
herzog alles gute kommt von drogen und
gott sei dank
das sind texte von der ihm auf den
ersten trip liebe auf den ersten test du
so leichtfertig geht da eine szene so
leichtfertig mit drogenkonsum eine szene
oder ich speziell um speziell speziell
musste erstmal lernen
diese verantwortungsvolle anzunehmen da
ich natürlich früher aus meinem
kinderzimmer heraus musik gemacht habe
und niemals für möglich gehalten habe
jemals so eine große reichweite zu
bekommen dass man über seine worte über
das gesagte oder das textlich verfasste
dann doch etwas mehr nachzudenken ist
vielleicht ich möchte an der stelle aber
gern noch mal bei ihm einen haken
ich für meinen teil hab dann natürlich
mit steigende reichweite und
bekanntheitsgrad auch diese
verantwortungsvolle angenommen und mir
dementsprechend auch mehr gedanken
gemacht über meine texte über meine
songs und seitdem ist das meer auch
unfassbar wichtig nicht nur zu
glorifizieren oder mein hedonistischen
lifestyle nach außen zu kehren in den
texten in den songs sondern eben auch
die schattenseiten aufzuzeigen
konsequenzen alles im leben hat zwei
seiten
aber der hedonistische lifestyle
gespielt trotzdem eine rolle er spielt
natürlich trotzdem noch eine rolle
green staunt durch den wald ist einer
deiner songs siehst du das inzwischen
kritischer oder war das auch eine
jugendsünde ist ein schmaler grat und
ich habe auch vier jahre den
cannabiskonsum der mein alltag bestimmt
hat auch erst mal raus gehalten weil ich
dachte ich hab' ich habe ja diese
verantwortung gegenüber allen jüngeren
hörern aber ich merkte dass ich mich
künstlerisch komplett selber an lüge
also nicht hat kann er bis zur musik
gebracht und das hat einen großen teil
in meinem leben oder und ich merkte dann
wie viele menschen auch dadurch
stigmatisiert werden und wie viele
erwachsene menschen die im bewussten
umgang pflegen mit dieser pflanze wie
den vom staat einfach das leben
erschwert wird ich muss darüber singen
und ich singe über die negativen seiten
und deswegen über die positiven seiten
ist so ein informations musik gegenüber
cannabis und auch ein bisschen politisch
den kampf aufnehmen die flagge schwingen
pro cannabis weil halt so eine große
ungerechtigkeit herrschen dieses land
also das ist ein schmaler grat wenn wir
das bewusst aber einfach den mund zu
halten wie es drei jahre in meiner musik
gemacht habe und über andere themen
gesungen habe also über cannabis war für
mich nie konnte so nicht mehr mit meinem
leben vereinbar weil es einfach zu glatt
gebügelt ist blieb wie siehst du das
alles gute kommt von drogen sind das
adäquate texte oder ist das eine gefahr
für kandidaten die vielleicht nicht ganz
so fest am boden stehen und sagen wir
probieren das jetzt auch machen
ich verstehe den gedanken aber ich bin
trotzdem der meinung dass leute die
rappen und die von vielen leuten gehört
werden ja auch eine vorbildfunktion
haben jemand dem man nacheifern ähnlich
wie influenza auf instagram und wenn ich
mir in pflanzen instagram angucke dann
will ich auch die klamotten haben die
sie tragen wichtig schuhe haben dann
will ich vielleicht auch die drogen
nehmen die die nehmen
und ich kann mir schon gut vorstellen
dass dann auch das rappen über drogen
möglicherweise auch noch über andere
drogen außerhalb von cannabis das kannte
beispiel ist ja tilidin dazu führen kann
dass mehr jugendliche um die es ja
gerade gehen muss dann auch anfangen
drogen zu nehmen und da gab es ja auch
verschiedene studien die gezeigt haben
dass der tee den konsum erheblich
angestiegen ist von den 15 bis 20
jährigen und das ist etwas was mir sorge
bereitet und ich glaube schon dass man
dann als jemand der im rampenlicht steht
eine verantwortung übernehmen muss und
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob alle rapper
dem so momentan gerecht werden wenn sie
weiterhin über drogen in der form rappen
dass sie sagen dass es voll cool und ok
ist das ist das sind ja ich will meinen
teil würde da gerne mal einen haken wenn
ich jetzt von uns gespräche speziell
gewinnen und mir noch mal darauf
verweisen dass wir primär uns auf
cannabis versteift habe ich früher auf
meine musik sehr sehr viele härtere
drogen auch thematisiert habe aber mich
davon auch ein bisschen wieder
distanziert habe also wenn stille dean
grose beschworen wird und ich dann
kleine kinder im bus tele den songs
singen höre dann denke ich mir auch dass
insgesamt der umgang im rap speziell
nicht mehr kritisch genug ist mit den
hilfen will was sagst du hast du den
eindruck die rap-szene geht insgesamt
einigermaßen ausgeglichen damit um und
problematisiert es auch oder wird mehr
verherrlicht als problematisiert es wird
auf jeden fall viel mehr verherrlicht
und es ist eher so dass das stellenweise
mal kontextualisiert wird dass es nicht
so gall ist drogen zu nehmen aber im
großen und ganzen sind drogen halt
nehmen was nicht schmuck coolen autos
und coolen klamotten halt so eines der
prestige im bohle die benutzt werden und
die abgefeiert werden als lifestyle und
sind daran die rapper schuld oder ist
die gesellschaft soll dass ihr das
zulässt ja das ist würde ich sagen
einfach beides also rap ist ja auch
immer halt ein spiegel von der
gesellschaft und das so viele rapper
inhalt so drogen affin sind und dass das
halt deren lifestyle bestimmen zeigt auf
jeden fall dass das halt sonst in der
gesellschaft auch einfach stattfindet
und da muss man sich ja natürlich guckt
also angucken wieso ist das so was
können wir da ändern
aber natürlich ist es auch so wenn ein
kapitalerhalt im video also drogen ab
feiert oder teddy inhalt zum thema macht
das dann fans dass dadurch entdecken und
sich mit kapital bereit infizieren und
dann sich die läden kaufen für linie
kannst du nachvollziehen dass es
menschen gibt die sagen leute wenn ihr
die ganze zeit darüber singt oder rappt
wie geil das ist drogen zu nehmen das
dann leute mal angestoßen werden auch
drogen zu nehmen
ja aber ich finde auch dass es der
falsche ort ist die musiker innen zu
verurteilen also ja diese debatte vom
offenen aufstand und bewirkt wie schön
die rund dir komplett so alles was er
gesagt habe nur genau weil wir jetzt
auch so viel darüber reden ist für mich
die schwangere frage in frage das macht
die deutsche drogenpolitik warum ist die
präventionsarbeit so schlecht restlöcher
nicht besser ausgestattet sind damit
umgehen zu können wenn eine rap song
oder auch eine alkohol werbung sagt
nimmt das na ja vielleicht ist das ja
sogar eine ganz gute vorlage wie du bist
ja politisch aktiv wenn du
drogenbeauftragte wärs nicht der beste
da muss man ja immer immer ein ganzes
archiv
was wäre deine politische agenda was ist
deine vision ich glaube das was für ihn
gerade gesagt hat es unglaublich
wichtigen aufklärung denn mein vater hat
mir zumindest immer gesagt als ich noch
jünger war gibt ja egal was du machst
rufen mich an ich hol dich ab das war
nicht eine wahnsinnig gute haltung von
meinem vater und ich hoffe dass wir so
auch als staat mit allen menschen
umgehen denn ich glaube jeder kann mal
was falsches machen jeder kann auch mal
mist bauen
wichtig ist dass wir die menschen
darüber aufklären dass sie möglichst
vorher wissen was könnte mit mir
passieren was passiert mit mir was hat
es möglicherweise für folgen und ich
glaube auch dass wir in deutschland
nicht genug über illegale drogen und den
konsum von illegalen drogen der ja
stattfindet aufklären das heißt das wäre
meine erste amtshandlung du hast ja nun
dürfte antworten aber ich würde gerne
einfach weil wir gesagt haben
erfahrungsschatz würde ich gerne einfach
du hast dich ja positioniert schon
mehrfach du hast dich zum beispiel
mehrfach auch gegen legalisierung
positioniert was ist dann passiert
ich muss sagen dass es ein thema ist das
nicht das einfachste thema ist gerade
auch in dieser szene und ich habe mich
schon einmal gegen die legalisierung
positioniert und habe danach einen
shitstorm bekommen aber
schlimmere sachen es gab auch
morddrohungen und ich würde mir vor
allen dingen auch wünschen dass wir
diese diskussion frei führen können dass
man alle positionen respektiert und dann
nicht danach menschen den tod wünschen
weil sie vielleicht eine meinung
vertreibt vertreten die man selber nicht
vertritt
ich glaube zumindest in diesem kreise
können wir davon ausgehen dass das nicht
passieren wird trotzdem gibt es
widerspruch nämlich widerspruch gar
nicht also ich wollte eigentlich nur
einen haken dass ich es besser finde ein
thema lieber zehn mal durchzukauen als
zu tabuisieren
da sind natürlich auch auf die eltern
gefragt die sowas gerne dann eher unter
den teppich kehren und zu hause nicht
zum thema machen dass sich ziemlich
schade finde auch also glaubt die eltern
stehen in der verantwortung der
beziehung natürlich geschenke der wm
einen rapper denn dass jugendarbeit
alles ich würd ich finde es ein bisschen
ein bisschen banal dass alles auf musik
und rappt abzuwälzen
ich würde auch noch was ja bitte danach
verliere ja ich glaube nicht dass
mangelnde aufklärung der grund ist dafür
dass leute drogen nehmen ich glaube das
ist ja schon common sense dass drogen
gefährlich sind und ich glaube das ist
halt egal ist also ja ich also ich habe
als jugendlicher auch gekifft und ich
kann natürlich auch viele leute die
kiffen oder drogen nehmen und sicherlich
dass auch irgendeine art von babbel in
der ich selbst stattfinden aber ich habe
noch nie einen menschen gesehen der
gesagt hat drogen sind ungefährlich
und ich glaube halt denen noch mal zu
erklären wie gefährlich das ist ändert
halten nichts an dem bedürfnis das dann
zu nehmen und ich glaube man woche hat
auf jeden fall eine andere strategie als
das verbot weil das verbot klappt nicht
zum beispiel andere lebensrealitäten
schaffen wo drogen nicht der einzige weg
sind oder vielleicht auch anderen zugang
zu therapeutinnen zu schaffen damit
leute lernen ihre probleme anders zu
verarbeiten als ich am rhein zu kiffen
aber also ich habe nicht das gefühl dass
leute nicht informiert sind wie
gefertigten sein können wie privat und
bleibst du trotzdem bei deiner position
legalisierung ist mist also mein
hauptargument ist dabei wir haben genug
probleme mit anderen drogen wenn man
jetzt drogen in einem pharmazeutischen
sinne auch versteht zum beispiel
medikamentenabhängigkeit mit alkohol mit
nikotin nicht weiß nicht warum wir eine
weit ein weit eine weitere substanz die
nachgewiesenermaßen zumindest für
jugendliche sehr sehr schädlich sein
kann legalisieren sollten
ich fände es besser wenn wir das nicht
tun
einfach weiterhin zu zeigen das ist
nichts was normal ist das ist nichts was
man tun sollte und das ist gefährlich
für dich so auch weiter die jugendlichen
vor allen dingen zu schützen ich weiß
das niemand
die position ernster vertritt dass man
es auch für jugendliche legalisieren
sollte aber ich glaube auch wenn wir es
in der gesellschaft generell
legalisieren für erwachsene oder aus
meiner sicht ab 25 wäre es richtig weil
da das gehirn ausgewachsen ist und sich
zu ende entwickelt hat dann also ich
glaube wenn das dann legalisiert ist
dann haben wir so eine gesellschaftliche
normalität dass auch kinder denken bei
mama und papa machen das ja auch dann
ist es ja okay wenn ich das auch machen
ähnlich wie es auch beim alkohol ist
manchmal gehören die ringer immer der
mit 60 ein alkohol kaufte 3 gegen rehden
nochmals prävention ganz wichtig es gibt
ja einen wissenschaftlichen stand der
sich damit beschäftigt was die beste
prävention ist und jugend welche gut
darauf vorzubereiten auf die risiken die
drogen mit sich bringen
das erste ist nicht im fokus auf
einzelne substanzen zu stellen wie es
jetzt auch die aktuelle anti cannabis
kampagne eine bundesregierung wieder
macht zu sagen wir müssen nur über
cannabis sprechen sondern es geht
vielmehr darum kompetenzen auszubilden
mit riskanten lebensentscheidungen mit
gruppendruck und so weiter umgehen zu
können
das zweite ist prävention macht sich
lächerlich wenn man jugendlichen sagt er
ich geb dir informationen ich geb dir
risikobewusstsein und so weiter darfst
nur zu einem ergebnis kommen
sonst wirst du bestraft hans hass
sanktionen zu befürchten sondern ganze
vielleicht ein führerschein erstmal
nicht machen usw
aber was heißt das dann plädierte dafür
alle drogen zu entkriminalisieren oder
nur cannabis wenn dafür alle
drogenkonsumenten die jetzt illegaler
drogen konsumieren zu schützen wie ge
hat ja gerade gesagt dass cannabis als
illegale droge auch so eine art
ausrufezeichen sein kann für leute die
sagen okay diese schwelle will ich nicht
überschreiten hab ich das richtig
verstanden
green ja was hältst du davon halte ich
für keine gute idee weil die letzten 50
jahre gezeigt haben es hat nichts
gebracht und außer dem jugendliche
wollen grenzen überschreiten und das ist
ja total guck mal wenn jetzt wird auf
einmal egal ist dann natürlich könnte
das ein falsches zeichen sein aber es
wird ein tabu brechen damit man darüber
reden kann und vor allen dingen ist es
dann nicht mehr so spannend weil man ja
macht jetzt nichts mehr illegal ist und
auch im zusammenhang nochmal
wie die musiker einfluss auf die
jugendliche haben mir hat man fan
geschrieben
green pinkl green bringt leute nicht zu
cannabis sondern cannabis zu green so
und weil es spiegelt ja wie gesagt eine
gesellschaft wider was jugendliche auch
so treiben über die stränge schlagen du
bist ja cannabis konsument der würdest
du dich als süchtig bezeichnet wenn dann
ist es bei jedem natürlich
auslegungssache richtig anfängt sucht an
ich bin jetzt keiner der morgens aus
stetten scheint rauch ich kann zwei drei
wochen lang einen joint rauchen und es
interessiert mich überhaupt nicht aber
ich weiß ist cannabis kann süchtig
machen da bin ich mir sicher wie zucker
süchtig machen wie hornos richtig machen
wie alles ich will das aber jetzt nicht
vergleichen mit sowas
dennoch ich glaube wenn die leute im
frühen alter anfang mit 14 15 16
regelmäßig zu konsumieren und dann auch
dieses holland platz mit rauchen kann
eine extrem starke sucht bei manchen
menschen passieren ja aber es gibt
möglichkeiten muss dieser sucht wieder
rausgekommen wir reden hier nicht von
einer heroinsucht also ich würde jetzt
nicht behaupten ich bin cannabis wichtig
ich hatte vielleicht mal eine tendenz
dazu als ich 15 16 war als beispiel noch
mal drüber sprechen ich meine martin du
kommst der anscheinend aus dem
medizinischen bereich wurde die leute
auch bezogen
ich bin per ausbildung psychotherapeuten
aber es ist dann nicht also ist es nicht
auch so dass auch gerade der
cannabiskonsum bei jugendlichen
psychosen hervorrufen kann und auch
deutlich schlimmere wirkung wort bringen
kann
als einfache sind also sind zwei
verschiedene dinge erst mal das ist so
und das wird man überall versucht es
irgendwie auslegungssache
das ist für uns zumindest nicht also sie
können ihre songs gibt es gibt klare es
gibt ein internationales
klassifikationssystem da steht quasi
drin was dazugehört einen knöchelbruch
zu haben und da steht auch drin was dazu
gehört
also wichtig zu sein und ich muss sagen
so blöd das ist weil es stimmt
cannabis ist sicher etwas was was länger
dauert davon abhängig zu werden
aber das ist immer die problematik bei
den stoffen die länger brauchen als bei
alkohol genau dasselbe
je länger die brauchen um so weniger
merkt derjenige der abhängig geworden
ist dass er abhängig ist weil sich das
quasi so über fünf zehn 15 jahre
mitunter die lebensrealität eingebaut
hat das ist ein normal
willkommen zu und das normalerweise auch
konsumenten dazu neigen das ist wie jede
menge untersuchung zu sich mit
konsumenten zu umgeben was eben dann
auch dazu führt dass der realitätscheck
die ganze zeit
naja du brauchst auch sofort klar da ist
ja okay jetzt sagst du
viele süchtige halten sich in dieser
blase auf wo es keinen realitätscheck
mehr gibt weil eben alle gleich
konsumieren ist doch genau das was du
gesagt hast die leute kommen wegen des
cannabis zu deiner musik dann ist doch
genau der fall gegeben alle in einer
blase keiner kontrolliert sich mehr
deutet darauf hin dass da möglicherweise
eine suchtproblematik im raum steht ja
wie definiert man wirklich sucht ist
konsumiere seit 15 jahren regelmäßig
cannabis auch täglich heute habe ich
noch nichts gekauft und ich habe auch
nicht vor heute zu kippen und das
interessieren als nächstes muss heute
nicht kiffen und ich kann aber das bin
ich habe die starke problematisieren ich
habe eine starke psyche ich weiß dass
menschen mit einem schwachen psychische
oder die große probleme haben die
cannabis lässt sich halt wegträumen und
seine sorgen vergessen und deswegen
nehmen wir leute drogen und auch
cannabis weiß sich betäubt und ich
glaube wenn dubai ein glücklicher mensch
bist erwachsen bist im leben steht dann
macht es viel weniger süchtig kann viel
weniger wichtig man muss also da muss
ich widersprechen
das ist so ich glaube das ist das
grösste falsche klischees sucht das
sucht entsteht weiß leuten schlecht geht
den weg gibt keine ärger aber kreide ich
hab' ich habe vor der drogenklinik war
da gebe ich dir technik in der alkohol
klinik gearbeitet und der überwiegende
teil dieser leute dort sind abhängig
geworden weil sie jahrelang getrunken
haben und warum haben sie getrunken was
normal ist zu trinken und sellschaft der
normale weg ist quasi du trinkst weil es
alle machen
wir bleiben beim alkohol das wird ja
jahr für jahr wird es mehr bei den
körper hält mehr braucht und irgendwann
setzen probleme ein dann keine ahnung
was den verlusten und führerschein oder
hasst irgendwie streit mit partnerin
partner und so weiter unter dem punkt
erinnern sich meistens die leute und
sagen ja stimmt dann irgendwann hatte
ich probleme und dann habe ich mehr
getrunken und dann kommen die quasi in
die therapie und sagen ich habe probleme
gehabt und deswegen hab ich konsumiert
und wenn du dir dann in der therapie
anguckt siehst du ja die haben die
forsche und zehn jahre konsumiert
einfach
zum runterkommen zum entspannen um spaß
mit freunden irgendwas und der
eigentliche punkt war da schon lange
erreicht die haben den blues im kopf
gesetzt also ich glaube da begeben wir
uns echt eine problematische diskussion
wenn man so denkt das trifft nur um
manche leute wir wissen jetzt dass es
alle leute treffen kann aber das war
ganz interessant wie wäre es denn wie
wäre es denn wenn du mal kinder hast
also eine tochter oder sohn 15 jahre alt
und die kiffen was machst du dann
erhöhte aufklärung betreiben ich würde
erzählt wird ihr alles über cannabis dem
was ich kenne welche erfahrungen gemacht
habe ich würde sie auf jeden fall nicht
bestrafen
ich würde dir wirklich die wird sie
darauf hinweisen was passieren können
wenn sie so weitermacht wird alle
negativen aspekte aufzählen er die
negativen stadt die positiven besonders
bei einem regelmäßigen konsum in so
jungen jahren wovon nicht ganz klar
brate überzeugt dass tee wird es das
auch
ich glaub ich hab jetzt keine studie
parat aber von dem was ich so in meinem
kopf gespeichert habe es ist schon
extrem gefährlich führen noch nicht voll
entwickelt das gehirn drogen zu
konsumieren kann ja aber kann findet
keinen grund an als vater zu sein ja
kompass schon
ich war risiko ist definitiv geändert ja
ich finde den ansatz auf jeden fall gut
ich find halten verbot also es gibt
sachen die kann einfach verboten zum
beispiel menschen umzubringen ist es
verboten und so allen ist ersichtlich
dass es so schön das muss man einfach
verbieten
aber ich bin bei anderen themen seiten
verbot oft so das letzte mittel was man
finden kann wenn man merkt so wo ich
weiß mir sonst nicht zu helfen
ich würde halt schon auch herausfinden
wollen ganz toll wie so manchen das
bedürfnis hat dann regelmäßig zu
konsumieren wenn er hat einmal ein joint
raucht oder so finde ich nicht schlimm
aber also abgesehen von aufklärung finde
ich echt wichtig herauszufinden
passiert das jetzt weil ein kind einmal
spaß haben will oder weil das etwas
kompensiert oder weil es nicht glücklich
ist also welche funktion hat dieser
drogenkonsum im leben eines kindes oder
überhaupt im leben eines menschen
was ist denn dann mit kindern die jetzt
nicht alles in den eigenen eltern gingen
keine vertrauensvoll an offenbar offen
reden können sondern irgendwie andere
ansprechpartner suchen
sie wissen jetzt wo ich weiß nicht mit
wem ich reden kann ich vertrauen kann
kommt eine strafe auf mich zu was
bedeutet das für dich ich bin ja gar
nicht für legalisieren wissen ja ihr
habt habt gewisse über einschneidende
übereinstimmung bei euren position ich
habe nicht stößt das immer so ein
bisschen auf
also musiker sind ja nicht der
verlängerte arm irgendwie dort
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung das werden sie auch nie
werbung gesagt und überhaupt also für
mich ist die überlegung so ein bisschen
fraglich also selbst wenn wir alle
merken rap verherrlicht drogen wissen
wir ja alle brauchen endlich also macht
ja schon immer von anfang an war halt
eine musik von drogenkonsumenten
was sollen die sagen rockmusik ist auch
ist es ja egal genau
also ich will das jetzt nicht auf rapper
endschießen aber genre ist es ist es
vollkommen irrelevant weil das wird so
bleiben also eigentlich sehr die
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung oder den rapper den du cool
finden ist also da muss man ja auch mal
schauen
ja aber das ist doch gerne erreicht denn
jemand hat man nicht deswegen genauer
verankert
das ist genau der punkt da eben diese
dinge für auf wir haben keinen zugriff
darauf
die kunst steuert sich dahin wo sie sich
hinsteuert und hier laufen dem hinterher
das ist immer so gewesen egal wer im
moment man kann ja durchaus verlangen
auch von künstlern in der öffentlichkeit
stehen dass es sich seiner verantwortung
bewusst ja also der rassismus sexismus
unter drogen
ich will meinen teil habe er diese
verantwortung auch gelernt anzunehmen
und mir das auch zu einem gewissen maß
auf die fahne geschrieben was ich vorhin
schon momente eben beide seiten der
medaille zu beleuchten und du arbeitest
ja offensichtlich eine suchtklinik
therapiezentrum ich bekomm tatsächlich
sehr sehr viel feedback auch von leuten
von therapeuten von patienten in diesen
einrichtungen weil ich eben die letzten
jahre auch mehr mühe gegeben habe songs
auch zu bringen zu veröffentlichen die
eben die kehrseite die schattenseiten
konsequenzen aufzeigen
und genau da bekomme ich immer unfassbar
viel positives feedback und es gibt mir
auch auftrieb und antrieb weiterhin auch
diese richtung zu verfolgen wir sind
jetzt langsam in der in der sogenannten
kompromiss runde ich hab drei thesen
vorbereitet die ich euch gerne verlesen
würde eigentlich richtig gern noch
einmal was zu kunstfreiheit sagen
unbedingt
weil wir da reingehen gut war ich fand
das stand das hier so mega im raum
und natürlich ist es so dass man in
deutschland das kunstfreiheit existiert
genauso wie meinungsfreiheit existiert
das heißt jeder mensch darf erstmal
einfach sagen was er oder sie möchte
aber das schützt halt nicht davor
verantwortung für die inhalte zu
übernehmen
und gerade im web ist das seit ein paar
jahren einfach so mega die diskussionen
dass künstler in die halt einfach
problematische gefährlichen oder sechs
sexistische irgendwie diskriminierende
inhalte produzieren dass unter dem
deckmantel der kunstfreiheit stellen und
sich somit vor der verantwortung drücken
und das geht halt nicht ja du darfst das
alles sagen du musst aber die
verantwortung damit da dafür tragen und
muss damit leben wenn leute dich dafür
richtig hart kritisieren und sich davon
abgrenzen das gleiche wie ja also finde
ich halt richtig wichtig für mich galt
gerade so ein bisschen sowie jani
künstler in dieses jetzt auch nicht so
das sprachrohr so die müssen wir jetzt
nicht in die verantwortung nehmen
ich wollte einfach damit sagen also wenn
mir geht es ja darum ich sehe jeden tag
das elend vor mir so ich habe heute
wieder drei leute entlassen weil die
rückfällig geworden sind uns nicht
verheizen riesen zeuge wir behandeln
rückfälle aber das ist wirklich bitter
so das ist das jeden tag du siehst es
leid weißt wo die leute atlanten und mir
geht es darum dass es also wege zu
finden wie das weniger wird so und ich
glaube einfach dass das was halt häufig
in der gesellschaft dann so an springt
ja dann müssen wir bei halt bei den
bösen kulturschaffenden anfangen oder
irgendwie das kann man alles machen aber
das wird an der an der strassen realität
wird das nichts ändern
und das ist das wollte ich einfach nur
dumm ist zumeist das ist ja die analogie
ist war schon am auslauf und
ballerspiele ja du sagst du das ist
nicht der hebel an dem wir an es ist
nicht so dass man mit folgender
folgender kompromiss thesen haben wir
vorbereitet hier ist der erste
kompromissvorschlag sämtliche drogen das
heißt auch zigaretten und alkohol
sollten legal nicht unter 20 jahren
abgegeben werden würdet ihr sagen er bin
ich dabei oder würde sagen das trifft
nicht spielt er nein höre ich da also
das heißt erst mal dass es eine
legalisierung von allen drogen greift
aber die dann ab 20 angeboten werden
oder was die these alle legalen drogen
sollen
20 abgeklatscht ok schwierig schwierig
bleiben
aber ich meine ihr seid zumindest in
teilen seid ihr schon relativ weit vorn
ende mit den kompromissvorschlägen
treibe ich euch wieder auseinander frage
nummer 12 stimmt ihr zu dass der aufruf
zum konsum von alkohol zigaretten und
cannabis aufhören muss und zwar sowohl
in der werbung stichwort werbeverbot als
auch in der popkultur zb in raptexte
auch in der kunst aufruf zum quatschen
also den ergo riet ihrer jagd aber
gründer herrn ein ja wäre damit also
werbung klar
aber du bist komplett nach vorne können
du würdest sagen das stimmt sofort zu ja
und nun 310 fragen hier kommt die
dreizehnte frage
wir sollten unsere energie weniger in
eine legalisierung diskussion stecken
als vielmehr die frage wie können wir
menschen stärken dass sie gar nicht erst
gefahr laufen in eine sucht abzudriften
[Musik]
ich werde das nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen
mein persönlicher standpunkt dazu es
irgendwie legalisierung nein weil das
sind weil das signal ist in der
einrichtung die es meiner meinung nach
nicht verdient eine kriminalisierung auf
jeden fall weil das macht das problem
nicht besser die leute müssen den
therapien durch ihren klassen natürlich
kann man darüber noch ganz ganz lange
und weiter diskutieren am ende habe ich
euch so gut hingekriegt dass er relativ
in der mitte steht und eine art in der
nähe eines kompromisses angekommen sind
da habe ich ganz gut hin manipuliert
natürlich wird diese diskussion niemals
auch für uns ja vollkommen klar und es
gibt bin mir ganz sicher dass auch ganz
viele fragen jetzt aufgekommen sind auch
bei menschen die vielleicht gerade
zuschauern die sagen ja was heißt das
eigentlich
wir haben in der video beschreibung
ziemlich viele tipps da gibt es auch
erste tests wenn ihr denkt wie ist das
eigentlich mit meinem konsum
da kann man sich online zumindest man in
die richtung bewegen und vielleicht
merkte eu vielleicht habe ich ein
problem das könnt ihr da müssen testen
aber ich denke einige argumente wurden
hier spannender weise ausgetauscht und
an euch ein ganz herzliches dankeschön
dass ihr euch hier her gegeben habt und
sogar auf einer dazu wir haben zu lange
die werbung dafür drogen zu nehmen
genauso wie alkoholwerbung finde ich
problematisch und da sind klare
erinnerungen an die rapper oder musiker
innen auch gut keine text seien rein zu
nehmen nimmt drogen und dann geht es dir
besser und ich habe schon das gefühl
dass beide halt sich so auf eine art der
verantwortung bewusst sind und dass auch
irgendwo in ihrer musik mit einfließen
lassen
aber auf der anderen seite hat schon
extrem drogen verherrliche texte über
richtig viele jahre halt so zum kern
ihrer diskografie machen und das finde
ich schon problematisch
ich bin meiner verantwortung bewusst
dennoch würde ich nicht behaupten ich
fange jetzt an nicht zu zensieren und
nicht mehr über diese dinge singen zu
können obwohl sie mein leben betreffen
in punkt der total vergessen wird ganz
häufig ist sucht das mittlerweile einer
der größten volkskrankheiten diesen
deutschland gibt und ich habe jahrelang
akademiker wichtige akademiker betreut
die verantwortungsvolle berufe haben die
noch auf arbeit gehen die familien haben
die ein objektiv so aussehen als würden
sie auf der gewinnerseite stehen und und
bei denen sie sucht zwar äußerlich
anders aus aber innerlich ist es genau
dasselbe wie auf der straße und das ist
was was oft vergessen wird und was passt
leider sehr tragisch ist und jetzt ihr
welche argumente haben euch überzeugt
denkt ihr vielleicht anders über
drogenkonsum als vorher
hier könnt ihr unseren kanal abonnieren
wir freuen uns auf eine spannende
diskussion
hier findet ihr ein weiteres video von
13 fragen und hier ein weiteres video
zum thema
[Musik]